to another one now in Baltimore where
the FBI says it stopped a plot to take
down the City's power grid two people
are under arrest a Neo-Nazi leader and a
woman accused of planning a series of
attacks for months senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is in
Washington this morning with more on
that Catherine good morning David the
FBI says the two suspects were fueled by
extremist ideology to quote completely
destroy Baltimore and inflict maximum
damage court documents allege Sarah
clendaniel of Maryland met Brandon
Russell of Florida while in federal
prison investigators Monday showed a
photo of Clint Daniel in a skull mask
often used as a symbol of white
supremacy Federal investigators allege
the two planned simultaneous attacks on
five Maryland substations similar to
recent successful attacks on the grid in
Oregon Washington State and North
Carolina law enforcement records allege
Russell started a local chapter of a
Neo-Nazi group called autom the group
promotes extremist ideology through
training videos that seeks start race
Wars and so chaos even before these
arrests a recent FBI intelligence report
reviewed by CBS News confirms nearly two
dozen crimes related to the power grid
including arson shootings as well as
tampering with equipment according to
that FBI report criminal coordination
and a motive remain unknown David
Catherine
Catherine Herridge in Washington thank
you